avec nous maintenant peter simons qu'on
retrouve à québec bonsoir monsieur
symons
bonsoir depuis john sims en 1840 vous
faites partie de la cinquième génération
des semaines à diriger l'entreprise
qu'est ce qui vous amène aujourd'hui
fondamentalement à faire cette
transition à prendre cette décision
maintenant
c'est une confluence de facteurs on sort
de la pandémie l'entreprise va très bien
financièrement on est solide et on jeu
pendant le cobp et dont on s'est entouré
d'un équipe de gestionnaires incluant
bernard leblanc qui est ici depuis
longtemps qui était seul et de la
gouvernance chez nous était solide et
donc l'ensemble de tous ces facteurs là
m'a amené à penser que le mama tu étais
bien de faire la transition mieux dépôt
active que de très active dans ces
situations là d'après vous parlez de
l'aco vide est ce qu'il y a une forme de
fatigue ou le désir tout simplement de
faire autre chose pour vous
oh non absolument proches lui même je
dirais redynamiser quand je regarde les
gens avec qui je travaille énormément de
plaisir avec des gens intelligents qui
sont redynamiser parce que v dont on est
haute on tourne la page honnêtement oui
commence à rêver on a des projets puis
on ne peut être les moyens certaines de
nos ambitions là font donc dans ce petit
ruisseau puis ça me permet de retourner
à mes anciennes amours j'ai commencé
dans les achats jeu demain au sein de
l'entreprise avec mon frère dans les
achats c'est un poste qui est plus
complexe que jamais avec les chaînes
d'approvisionnement
les défis environnementaux je veux
accélérer notre programme vision donc ça
me permet de revenir à mes premiers
amours puis focus sur la pédagogie on a
plein d'acheteurs
et acheter ici
incroyable et j'ai envie de partager ses
connaissances que j'ai parce que vous
êtes chef marchand et le propriétaire le
copropriétaire toujours d'une maison
simons qui demeurent entre vos mets à
votre frère yaya vous est-ce que vous
évaluer la possibilité
d'aller plus loin de vendre
éventuellement l'entreprise où c'est
complètement exclu
non c'est beau même pas son matador
présentement je suis content avec des
partenaires tout s'est stabilisé dans
l'éden dame dernières années on vient de
renouveler tous nos financements
nécessaires pour avancer avec nos
projets pour l'avenir
je suis très content d'être avec avec
eux donc pour nous c'est un question
bâtir une entreprise ce point question
tout n'est pas de transactionnel
d'enlever
noble pis je présume que dans une
entreprise familiale comme la vôtre et
avec la longue histoire qu'elle a est-ce
que dans votre esprit il est exclu que
les sims puisse vendre la maison simons
aux exclus je suis
exclu une forme pas des portes non mais
c'est pas son antre adore et on pense
continuer je serai pas là un jour là on
décède tous dans sûr on a cinq on a cinq
enfants
c'est 7-6
7/1 entreprises rempli avec joie puis
créativité puis avec tel plein de
potentiel mais il faut avoir le plaisir
le patient et on n'impose pas sa sueur
les autres il faut laisser les choses
évoluer je pense avec monsieur leblanc
bernard seux tel choix et l compétences
il ya maintenant vigueur un redoublement
peut-elle au sein de l'entreprise point
de vue des idées qui toujours bon j'ai
énormément plaisir à travailler avec à
bâtir avec c'est un bâtisseur et on peut
pas tout planifié dans le vip et voilà
cela dit vous parlez de cinq enfants est
ce que parmi ces enfants certains
auraient pu ou pourrait diriger
l'entreprise
oui
5 incroyable enfin ils ont tous leurs
intérêts ils sont jeunes encore il
poursuit un petit peu lors leurs rêves
leurs visions de leur vie en a qui
qu'ils soient ils ont toutes sortes
d'intérêts
delas du santé jusqu'aux affaire dont on
verra mais je pense qu'ils ont des
choses à vivre et il faut ce qui arrive
aujourd'hui or arrivée d'un à mon âge
l'âge de mon frère puis l'âge des
enfants d'une certaine sansal il enlève
peut-être impressions et ça me permet de
vivre
leur jeunesse et le faire leur choix
leur propre vitesse est ce que vous êtes
préoccupé par le contexte économique
actuel le choc inflationniste qui semble
se dessiner
c'est un environnement extrêmement
volatile non seulement l'inflation mais
les chaînes d'approvisionnement
je suis de nature préoccupe les
préoccuper pas plein d'affaires c'est
pour ça qu'on a vécu pour 180 dans le
fond c'est une bonne habitude à voir
donc oui à date on navigue les eaux
raisonnablement bien mais on a encore
beaucoup de défis parce que l'inflation
c'est un défi point de vue de
l'approvisionnement mais on parle aussi
de transport évidemment politiquement
mondialement on voit le d'autres
facteurs comme en ukraine qui nous un
impact et parmi tout ça c'est pas juste
de gérer les crises de le média cd aussi
de
imaginé jusqu'à quel point on pourrait
créer une économie circulaire avec nos
produits modifiés nettement l'impact de
dos et de g us de nos chaînes
d'approvisionnement donc beaucoup de
défis une préoccupation
préoccupation devient rapidement et
motivation aussi on voit les problèmes
comme des opportunités et là vous
prévoyez une ouverture prochainement
d'un nouveau magasin n'est ce pas à
pointe claire sur l'île de montréal il
ya une quinzaine de magasins dans votre
réseau est ce que les 15 magasins vont
bien
ils vont tous bien y contribuent tous je
peux vous dire que notre marque
évidemment en dehors de québec n'est pas
ce qu'il est à québec et au québec dû
aller 191 empilés cinq générations
qu'ils ont travaillé ici dans au québec
donc on a encore du travail à faire pour
se faire connaître et expliquer qui nous
sommes
en dehors de québec et ça aussi c'est un
je suis motivé par ce défi leur point de
vue de communiquer notre raison d'être
est pourquoi pour notre expérience
service clientèle et préparer
tranquillement le 200e anniversaire de
la maison simons
vous savez il y en a 27 entreprises
d'être moi qui ont plus que 200 ans au
monde et wii sont privées familiales
donc ce que je serai encore là pour voir
ce jour n'est là je pense que ça serait
une fierté oui ben j'espère que vous
avez raison quand même c'est fillion
vous avez raison voilà exactement
j'espère que vous avez raison puisque ce
geste était tout jeune monsieur
57 ans viendront pas où 56 oui
exactement donc oui donc oui c'est un
objectif écoutez cécile ludique
peut-être mais mes écoles aujourd'hui on
accompli quelque chose que
une personne sur cent un propriétaire
sauf si un ou deux propriétaires sur
cinq sont capables de peut-être réaliser
ces transitions là
donc oui écoutez cependant ça comme on
dit est
capable de le faire c'est bien monsieur
ça et me dis merci bonne chance pour la
suite merci d'avoir été avec nous ce
soir merci merci pour votre état pour
voir nos émissions en entier rendez vous
sur la chaîne ici et redit